bachchi
Takashi oh the grace of all-time there
you go
it's a grace of all time and if you use
one I was hoping you didn't read if you
healing Akashi you're crazy
somebody make the argument somebody make
the argument against Akashi I don't
understand it I don't either
make argument against ik I don't think
he's gonna last as long as you do but
you know how long he'll ask but they
[ __ ] your baby mama right they kidnap
you they beat you up they try to kill
you or they say they're gonna kill you
and they [ __ ] with your mom and you're
supposed to be loyal to them know that
yeah that's not the full story what's a
good story no I'm saying we don't know
the full story there's no way that he
was rolling with these guys and all of a
sudden they just all just turned on him
like that I mean he got right and they
didn't right yeah and that's why I'm
saying you're supposed to take care of
your people if your people rolling we
just want to take anything he didn't
take care of them yes are they yeah
there's no reason to steal from you dude
if you're being taken care I disagree I
think you want them you'll hire Olin I
think when you hire thieves they do
thieving [ __ ] like these [ __ ]
steal for if you're part of a gang right
there is selling drugs and like involved
in illegal activity you don't know how
to turn that off it's not like or very
few people know how to turn that off so
it's like it's not like all of a sudden
when you make money or we're gonna go
legit
I'm gonna accept my you know 5% the
Takashi gives me or I'm gonna do that
nah they're like hold up I could get a
lick over here okay we got a million
coming in okay I can actually scrape a
few little bit off of this like I could
do this show for 80 grand okay if I cut
this deal on the side I'll give him the
60 and I'll keep 20 I think they're
trying to get money from it all how to
play that I can understand like just
trying to skim [ __ ] off the top which is
still [ __ ] up
but I'm talking about the kidnapping
moms and [ __ ] like that that is hey I'm
getting young baby or some [ __ ] okay
okay so let's back up I think they broke
the trust first by trying to steal and I
think that came out a while back
remember when like he was supposed to do
some show and then he cancelled a bunch
of dates he said cuz [ __ ] were
stealing from me oh yeah yeah because I
believe he was told he was only gonna
make like 14 mm of some show but really
he was making like 22 or some [ __ ] like
that so David Moore
they told him a different number than
what and that's and that is like it not
he so that you just cut them all off
like cold turkey
as you should yeah but then if you don't
stop my money now they're gonna that's
not his fault if that's how it happened
what I was thinking maybe could happen
is like you know he's thrown all his
money around and maybe they think he's
got it like that but he doesn't
maybe he's flexing for more than this
agreement maybe they buy into it and he
doesn't have that money looking to him
like why is he not taking care of you so
[ __ ] rich we're sitting here with
nothing or whatever [ __ ] you and I mean
that's how all about some money but if
that is the case if they're if you're
getting thirty thousand a show and
somebody says hey you're getting paid
twenty and then they take ten off the
top [ __ ] you you're not getting me the
shows I highly doubt his gang member
friends are getting him a [ __ ] gig
and del C del whatever so for Nia the
money is one element the other element
is that he wasn't blood initially he got
with this gang and like then he started
repping Troy way and they were his
muscle and so they're the ones taking
the risk like shooting that [ __ ]
rappers about beating people up and
robbed him all the [ __ ] but he's
making those calls like we saw them on
the TMZ tape like saying yo go send some
shots I did or whatever whatever
whatever so it's like how all of it
works yeah but I'm saying if you guess
if you're one of the generals and you're
making the orders is like now you with
the gang too so now if the whole gang
got caught up in the RICO you got to go
down with the gang as well you can't
just make Rico to people real quick oh
that's um it's I don't know what it
stands for but it's basically just a law
that the federal government came up with
to take down gangs Giuliani actually
found it and that's how he broke them
off yet pretty racketeering influenced
in corruption organization yeah so it's
like if we can prove you know one
contacts you making like actually doing
the crime but if we can prove you roll
with the gang that did that crime you
all go down so this is the thing how the
Mafia was really brilliant in the way
they insulated the top dogs so there was
no real way to really get to the top
dogs so they had to create some some law
where they could punish someone who was
associated for it
and I think there's Rico and then
there's another one called like a
conspiracy to commit crime or whatever
then so it's like if there's a phone
call about the crime that's gonna be
committed even if you don't commit it
you're tied into it yeah so these were
laws basically made to break the Dawn's
because the Dons were completely
insulated from any bad [ __ ] was
happening and then they start to use
them on like you know the drug gangs and
that kind of SH like that and it Rinna's
works I mean they got the whole [ __ ]
Bobby shmurda right like all them they
got a RICO mm-hmm right so I guess with
with the six nine [ __ ] it's tricky
because you don't know which came first
the chicken or the egg right my
assumption is it's probably a little bit
of both right it's like a little bit of
envy like what Akash was saying right
and maybe they weren't being paid as
much as they thought they should be and
to be honest they're not managers Yeah
right like their muscle their muscle but
also they're the validating component in
your career if you're gonna be thug guy
yeah you need this gang to be thug guy
not only to protect you but to prove
that you are blood when you say you're
blood so they have every right in my
opinion to have a negotiation with
Takashi and be egg listen Takashi you're
like a short fat Mexican kid without us
what value do we bring to you and if he
says five percent then they could be
like nah if he says they see if he's a
10% they could be Agnon it could be
50/50 you don't know they have to decide
what that's worth Takashi's clearly the
criminal mastermind or just genius not
even criminal like he found a way to
make a career for himself
it's like [ __ ] brilliant what he did
yeah so they have to go okay maybe I'll
take you know what maybe I'll take 1% of
career earnings of this guy who might
make a hundred million dollars in their
career that's pretty nice they have to
have the foresight to look at that and I
think what happens is when you're when
you're a guy who for a living gets money
quick when you're a guy who's like [ __ ]
I need to pay rent I'm gonna go rob a
[ __ ] when you just think about
money now it's hard to think about money
in the future and I think they made a
[ __ ] up situation I think they stole I
think they did some like well foul [ __ ]
with his baby mama
I think he cut him off and then from
there on then the other stuff happens
but I think they started it acha takashi
is no incentive to start it think about
it he knows he needs muscle he knows he
needs protection why would he [ __ ] those
guys over
I mean if let's say if those guys think
hey I'm supposed to be getting a
percentage of the earnings what
Takashi hasn't really adjusted my
payment but all of a sudden we see him
cop in houses whips like the money's
rolling in but for some reason they're
not rolling in for them I think you can
grow resentment especially this is not
really my dude is not my friend
there's just somebody who attached
himself to me this is yeah so it's like
nah like I can just see resentment
growing you also can see wrongs on both
sides but at the end of the day if
you're doing criminal activity together
you go down together because you're
doing it together is if I wait you're a
clip real quick to that though is um
that's the tricky thing about if you're
doing criminal activity together you go
down together and why that doesn't work
and Takashi spoke about this in his live
is that he's like what assurances do I
have if I didn't rat that they want to
kill me in jail they were trying to kill
me outside of jail you don't think
they're gonna send someone at me in
prison to kill me of course they are so
what incentive do I have to not read so
wit Bobby shmurda for example Bob that
makes sense though right Bobby shmurda
could have took a deal to rat on his
dudes not do any jail time and they
would have got a lot more time but the
difference is those dudes and the way
you're saying it it's a business
agreement but I would also say to this
if you're gonna get in business with
bailed [ __ ] know that if things
go awry they're gonna handle things the
way they know how
that's a fact well you knew what you
were getting into but the difference
between the shmurda and the takasu
situation is schmurder and his boys were
on the same page murderers boys weren't
trying to kill murder and [ __ ] his girl
into all this fashion murder right I'm
saying like I see both sides I see
reasons on both sides but how long mr.
Kashi in jail I think a year I believe
he was supposed to do it he was he was
in jail more than a year right well one
year I think waiting for trial and then
it was supposed to be like the sentence
was two years so he did one year waiting
for trial so they count that time right
then I think he did like six
once he got out and then he got out of
early Quran but my feeling is like if
they couldn't prove anything on any of
them he is no reason to snitch no I'm
pretty sure they had enough cuz once the
feds call them feds usually don't lock
people up until they have like I guess
they got like a 90 what is like a nice
seven percent conviction rate yeah so
they only coming through when they know
it's going down it's just to me we the
we talk in absolutes about snitching
because it has such a great rhyme with
it snitches get stitches this that the
other and I understand if you're
operating outside the law you don't have
to involve the law I understand that
from a culture perspective and the law
ain't necessarily been fair to you
that's true why [ __ ] the law what's the
point right [ __ ] you right first you but
at the same time I I find it very
difficult to be loyal and to uphold the
code to people who are not loyal to you
I just don't understand that I wouldn't
do that I wouldn't in a [ __ ] are you
kidding me you come at me you steal from
me you do any of these types of [ __ ] and
I'm gonna be loyal [ __ ] that
at that point we have a home comic
friend rail battle he would always have
this bit about how like the snitches get
stitches [ __ ] like you should never
snitch it's a little crazy and then the
second he would say that would get crazy
then he'd be like basically the joke was
like if a guys molesting somebody I
don't remember punchline but that's a
snitch situation that's not like you're
not whatever you're not keeping the
[ __ ] cold by not reporting somebody
who's molesting kids whatever no audio
any black audience we get so
uncomfortable the whole time there would
you be like nah you could feel the
resistance from the room and that always
blew my mind like like even if a dude is
[ __ ] kids you don't snitch on that
guy didn't you remember when Cam'ron he
was asked that same question he's like
now I wouldn't snitch I just move away
[Music]
all right how about this everybody
talking to snitches get stitches [ __ ]
question everybody with this snitches
get stitches
whatever snitches get stitches [ __ ] they
got no problem posting those two white
dudes that kill the the Ahmad Arbor II
know but see now that's different this
civilians and now no civilians and then
there's people who are actually doing
crime the snitches only particularly
it's only that rules only for people
that are doing criminal stuff together I
mean so it's like us so for no reasons
criminal no I'm talking about so a
civilian civilian just go telling on
some molester that's fine or regular
civilian who's not doing crime telling
the police on a drug deal or some [ __ ]
like that at the end of their block if
that's fine too because they're not in
the streets and not part of that coat
it's the ones like if you're involved
like Takashi was doing these crimes with
them so that's why you don't snitch
gotcha no that makes sense yeah that
makes sense it only applies to people
who are doing criminal activity huh if
you're a civilian you're allowed to
snitch all you should not true [ __ ]
think are gonna snitch they'll kill
witnesses they'll do oh well I'll do
whatever they can to keep themselves
alive yeah but I mean that's that's
different that's just [ __ ] when they're
like nah he's a civilian leave him alone
until you need to rob somebody it seems
like you be robbing civilians that's
what I'm saying the code is flimsy the
code is flip-floppy but actually like I
remember I was in the courts the biggest
robbing cases were like drug dealer
robbing another drug dealer cuz it's
like neither one wants to get police
involved right both operate with a lot
of cash on hand because they can't push
it in banks and [ __ ] like that so that's
like the best person Rock but you got to
be honest that's a big come up to if
you're willing to take the risk of rob
my drug dealers like you're not gonna
just get the hundred dollars and it's
wallet you could get ten thousand yeah
coke like that's a big like there's no
point in robbing a civilian like the
most you get some credit cards that
they're just gonna cancel in two seconds
yeah thing it's like honestly I feel
like robbing is kind of stupid it's gone
done
it must've right yeah there's no credit
cards what are you getting off yeah you
might get a watch or something like that
but if you came up to me and you're like
I'm not suggesting this but you're like
if you said give me your wallet and then
beat me up or if you just said you know
yo man like I don't want to [ __ ]
shoot you can you just give me the cash
you got I'll just give you a cash yeah I
also enjoy the beating you up we I'm
just saying hypothetically in the past
you would prefer not getting into an
altercation so you just yeah just say
I'd rather have it go smooth how would
it go hypothetically now you just be
like yoke and to your pockets thank and
they don't empty you emptier for now
what if yeah what if it we start to like
fight in that kind of [ __ ] I mean then
you fight and then you keep record now
but I'm just saying it's like people
don't really rob civilians that much and
now the laws have changed where now it's
a felony if you rob anything over I
believe eight hundred dollars uh just by
taking a phone so this is really
interesting so yeah it's called grand
larceny yeah I think everything is it
five hundred or like a thousand exact
number yeah how they need it so low
where it's like basically you take
anything awesome what is yo almost a
felony it's not only they're so low it's
that we're all the sudden walking around
with things that are way more expensive
yeah like it'd be rare to walk around
with something was a thousand dollars if
you're not a rich dude this guy like a
nice watch yeah back in like the 90s 80s
or whatever exact but it's super normal
that you got your computer or you got
your cell phone you got these things
that happened we were thousands of
dollars so when someone just grabs your
backpack back in the day someone
grabbing Northface backpack and they
grab your transport or some [ __ ] now if
you've got a laptop in there you gonna
[ __ ] prison bro yeah yeah if they
press charges up yeah man maybe it's
good so now whether you saw someone that
killed like biggie or Tupac like street
code Street so we're gonna but what they
didn't I mean they did though the guys
we did it
did I get it yeah the guys kid biggie is
that really yeah
they believe that yeah and what I kept
like pretty certain they know who the
guy was and what about Pok
I'm pretty sure they God they think it's
either that cop that undercover cop that
was working with what's-his-face Suge
yeah and there was a suspect of one
other person I'm sure the person he got
into a fight with at the casino earlier
yeah [ __ ] out of that yeah they beat up
dude yeah and what about they do they
kill nipsey they found him oh really
well what's up with him is he still like
I'm pretty sure he's on solitary because
if he's in general pop they're gonna get
to him so he so he turned something to
protect themselves pretty much yeah damn
bright yeah streets take care of screeen
Bastas yo so uh totally separate note I
don't know